The head of the
Wagner mercenary group
admits his forces in Bakhmut
have been, quote, pretty battered.
But Yevgeny Prigozhin
insists his mercenaries
have practically destroyed
the Ukrainian army, again,
those are his claims and continue
he does, saying they will win the battle
for the eastern city.
Ukrainian officials,
of course, dispute
that claim,
saying they are the ones
that are keeping control of Bakhmut.
Now, the US believes
there are about 6000
Wagner mercenaries
currently fighting there
and they are suffering serious losses.
A top U.S.
general is saying Ukrainian
defense forces
are, quote,
inflicting a lot of death
and destruction on those guys.
Ben Wedeman
joins me now from eastern Ukraine.
And Ben, really curious
to get your insights here.
You've been on the ground there
for a few days.
What more have you learned
about the state of play,
especially there in Buck Mount?
And I know that you've heard
from both sides
in terms of each
giving their position
and sometimes putting
forward disinformation
Yes.
I mean, seriously, the
situation is unclear.
Back in January,
we were almost every day in Bermuda.
But since the 21st of February,
the Ukrainians declared
Bermuda a red zone.
So volunteers and journalists
simply cannot go there.
So I can't tell you firsthand.
But what we are hearing
is that the Ukrainians
are still controlling perhaps 40%
of the city
that they have lost some ground
over the last few weeks.
But the Ukrainians insist that the lines
and their words have stabilized.
Now what you have ongoing
there is really it's being called
a meat grinder
where you could call it a bloodbath.
There are
heavy casualties on both sides now.
The ratio of dead
Ukrainians to dead
Russians, it's not clear.
Some put it as much as five dead Russians
for every one dead
Ukrainian Others say it's
more like one dead Russian
or rather
two dead Russians for one Ukrainian.
So the battle is intense and certainly
what we've seen is that
there are many Ukrainian forces
deployed on the outskirts of Borehamwood.
They've dug defensive positions
there's lots of armor in the area.
So in the event
the Ukrainians can no longer
hold back mud,
they hold the high ground
to the west of the city
and they certainly would be able
to stop a Russian advance there.
It's been really a battle of quantity
versus quality.
The Russians obviously
have a huge new numerical advantage
and certainly in terms of weaponry
their weaponry may be antiquated,
but they have a lot of ammunition,
which we've heard
from Ukrainian officials
that they don't seem to be suffering.
The Russians,
that is
from a shortage of artillery shells.
But certainly
the situation is more or less stalemated,
but at a high price to both sides.
Both to both sides.
And we have been hearing that
quite clearly.
We just went over what U.S.
officials had said.
I wonder what you make of the Wagner
leader for Ghosn.
He admitted, okay,
that they are battered.
But what about his claims
that he's
inflicting great pain on Ukraine
and the fact that he continually gives it
literally gives it
to the Russian defense ministry
about what he needs on the ground
and what he hasn't gotten on the ground
Well, we've heard him
complain quite publicly time
and time again
about not receiving
adequate support
from the Russian defense ministry.
And specifically the Russian army.
He's got a feud with those people.
And at the end of the day,
the force that has the resources
is the Russian army.
And all reports indicate that Wagner,
the Wagner
group, has lost
thousands of its fighters.
Now, I suggest
we put that in quotation marks.
Many of them are simply convicts
with very little in the way of training.
And we've been
we've spoken to Ukrainian soldiers
when I was here last January
who said that
they the Russians use
a very specific tactic.
They will send waves of these
basically cannon
fodder convicts
and others, poorly trained people forward
to allow for the Ukrainians to open fire.
They expose their firing positions
and then
better trained, better
equipped Russian troops
will then focus their fire
on the Ukrainian.
So it comes at a very high price
to the Wagner group.
And but it's also inflicting a high cost
on the Ukrainians.
But Prigozhin, it's
hard to say
how much longer he can carry on with a
this feud
with the Russian military hierarchy
and how much longer his military force
can go on taking these high losses Paula.
Yeah,
especially what may be to come in terms
of a change to that stalemate
as spring has now sprung in Ukraine.
Ben Wedeman
for us on the Eastern front lines.
I appreciate it.